like scientific scientology
for face value they push this book
called dianetics
which basically you know it it um
it talks about being productive and
getting things
done and bettering yourself um and once
you get
inside and start to pay them all kinds
of money i mean that's a huge thing is
they want money from you that's how they
that's how they survive um besides being
tax exempt
of course but once you sort of level up
in scientology now they reveal to you
this galactic confederacy ruled by this
overlord by the name of xenu
and you don't hear about any of that
until you get inside and pay them a
bunch of money
otherwise people would just think it's
complete horseshit
yeah you're right um that is the
i would describe as the worm on the hook
when you catch the fish you got to put
the worm on the hook you just give them
the hook
and the fish will never bite so the worm
on the hook for satanists
is what you describe this the satanic
temple claiming
that uh it's about worship of self
and they'll probably bring in nice
attractive phrases like self
esteem self realization etc etc
and as with the book dianetics for
scientologists
this is the worm on the hook for
satanists draw people
in but the thing about
satanism is that as with scientology as
many people have alleged i think
um once you're in it's pretty hard to
get out
you may even find yourself being
seriously threatened
when you try to get out right so once
you
bite on that attractive looking worm
like a fish you're on the hook
and it's not going to be easy to get
yourself off the hook
and there's going to be a lot of
fighting that you're going to have to do
so it's better not to get in in the
first place now what is your
what have you studied on anton levay is
he do you think
anton levay was involved with any sort
of
child abuse or this pedophilia
what i understand about la va is that
there have there has been at least one
allegation of sra against him
apparently by a family member
i don't dwell a lot on u.s
sra cases for the simple reason that
i've got more than enough
uk sra cases that more than
fill up my plate but this is what i
understand
from a u.s uh sauce who works on sra
that there has been a serious allegation
of sra
against uh anton ave at least one
if not more um
the fact of the matter is with satanists
especially
you you should never take what they
claim publicly at face value you've got
to look
deep behind because
they are masters of deception
you know i describe satanists as uh
oscar-winning actors and actresses
because they put on oscar-winning
performances
all their lives imagine some of them are
very respectable they do respectable
jobs some of them are even in government
but at night when they believe that no
one is watching
and they're at their coven meetings they
do the most horrific things
to children of vulnerable adults
and then they go back to respectability
the next morning and
carry on with their uh
respectable jobs sometimes very highly
paid professional jobs and so
they leave this double life all their
lives
and so they're very good at deception
they're very
well practiced at it i remember once
meeting
a former senior police detective
in the uk who by the way is a satanist
abuser himself
i know from various victims who've seen
him
at the rituals and
one of whom was even sexually assaulted
by him
and he was
acting the act very convincingly as the
former
police detective and speaking very
convincingly
and the interesting thing is he was
trying to persuade me
not to describe sra as satanist ritual
abuse
because the one thing satan is hate is
for
the finger to be pointed at satanists
or satanism they hate that
which is all the more reason why we need
to say sra satan's ritual abuse
because then we are pointing to the
source
of sra which is satanist
ritual satanist beliefs without saying
to his beliefs
there would be no sra you see that's why
they hate that so much they
they need to at least get the word satan
is dropped from sra
to help conceal themselves and
every time we expose them we are helping
to protect children
by making it harder for them to remain
hidden
and to remain in secret and we make it
harder for them to mainstream themselves
and get respectability as a major
religion
because you cannot recognize
a belief system that encourages serial
torture of children serial killing
and serial sexual sex abuse of children
[Music]
to become a a religion it's it's it's
like saying well you know why don't we
we take the practices of ted bundy and
turn that into a religion you know
because
you're just giving a license to
sociopaths to start their own religion
if you do give that kind of recognition
to the people behind sra
you see but they want they want the
financial benefits they want the
political benefits
of becoming a respected religion
and they are further down the road on
this in the us than they are in the uk
in the uk at the moment they're still
trying to pretend they don't exist
but we know that they exist